you
do we have any questions in the audience
for for our panelists so if you do just
walk up to either the mics here we can
also fire up on Twitter I can check your
things and on wasting I'll turn on my
wasting so location-based services Oh
actually I have my phone because it
interferes so yes we have a question my
question is for David is melted the
innovation and strategy for Tencent I
mean well I like up tents in the very
much I use it QQ and WeChat everyday but
right now 10:17 is a kind of a public
enemy in the market because you know
every time you see something some new
products or some new business model
market can say we're copied and the
leverage is customer huge customer base
to kill those young companies and stops
so I don't know it's a kind of the
strategy of the company or next day we
will see another QQ Alibaba or kill you
drew fubar like that so is that the
strategy of the company where you keep
it or will change it in the future so I
think I understand your question yeah
I've actually never so usually my
colleagues in China have to deal with
these places which is awesome point if
you have a company or your student yeah
these students okay you're thinking
about a company okay so yeah I heard
some people clapping - so I guess it's a
it's a big problem I'm not very exposed
to that like this is the first time I've
had this question before but I do read
the articles and the magazine I know
when I was back in China three months
ago that was like the front page topic
on a lot of magazines was even why
doesn't China have a facebook because
Tencent kills every company it was
something like maybe like didn't make
sense to me I thought like hey we're the
Facebook in China and like we were been
around before Facebook but somehow we
kill faith I don't I didn't really get
it so obviously like I'm gonna have a
defensive answer to that but you know I
think you're right like we offer a lot
of kinds of services and you know if one
of our services does well that means I
guess that means someone shred I mean
it's not necessary the case that like if
we do well someone has to shrink I think
there's a scenario where like there's
many cases where we grow like in games
like we have me of great games with
really huge numbers but there's all
kinds of other gaming companies out
there that are doing fine it just really
depends on the game so you know I don't
really know what to say it's not
it's not a strategy of the company to
see smaller companies not do well that's
certainly not the way we think about it
but we definitely target certain areas
that have been sensitive I think like
when we did our browser and the browser
Lee grew that was sensitive I guess
there's a huge debate when we went back
antivirus and then it became a republic
with the company 360 and let's not even
go there because it's just like I think
people like took sides without even
knowing exactly what's happening but
like yeah I mean it's sensitive we go to
different areas I think we're aware of
that
what we do though as a company is we we
find areas we think are strategic and
add a lot of value to our users and we
definitely are going to offer a solution
there to try to be more I think we went
through a long period of time as Tencent
where we pretty much did everything
ourselves and for a long time at $0.10
we didn't invest in other companies
either there's those kind of Duncans
point earlier so I think that that
didn't give us many opportunities to
share in our success with other
companies but I think we're doing a lot
more investing now we tend to invest
actually in China we don't tend to
acquire companies we tend to like invest
10 or 15% in companies and I hear from
our M&A team that we made you up to like
a hundred deals this year so there's
like 100 companies in China alone
there's probably like a hundred
companies that are getting money from us
and hopefully they're not bad-mouthing
us but you never know right but you know
and and I think the probably the most
important development in the past like
18 months or so about us doing more with
smaller companies that we don't work
with necessarily is that we have an open
platform kind of like Facebook it
expands more of our services than just
Facebook we have you know like on our
Qzone service which is kind of like a
social networking equivalent in China or
instant messaging service QQ we have all
kinds of opportunity for apps to go on
we call it open platform our internal
teams complain about that a lot
saying hey like now any game company can
go on our open platform Qzone and that's
really putting a lot of pressure on us
inside $0.10 like seems like the company
isn't giving us enough support because
now any company can just you know go on
our Qzone platform and they're totally
kicking butt and like we're actually
limited by the amount of resources we
can get from 10:00 CET we don't get
enough ads we don't even have support in
the companies outside raised BC and they
completely attack our Qzone platform so
you know it's like I think that's been a
great a great advance in terms of like
our ability to work with a lot of
companies so so for example like if the
company that you're concerned about
their if they did accuse onap they could
probably very aggressively do all kinds
of things to try to take as much of the
tense at user basis they wanted to in
that we would kind of celebrate that
because we want all of our app partners
to be very successful but you know I
can't really you know well we're going
to compete with other companies cuz we
just offer so many types of services and
you know that's just kind of how it is
sorry I don't have a better answer for
you on that one
question over there I'd love to just say
somebody everyone felt like Oh Tenzin's
awesome what a great answer but you know
it's complicated we're competing the
market so sorry thank you I also have a
question with David so don't worry my
question isn't that tough so um I hear
one point you mentioned is that like
China is trying to uh trying to spread
their own my iPad there on a poster back
then and I'm curious about there how
would you how exactly do that would that
be more realized by internal growth for
exam you cook you culture your own
environment or by like burning people to
advanced places like Silicon Valley to
make them fit in environment and let me
bring back their benefits I'm asking
because I am Miss Lucy it's a company
that brings Chinese entrepreneurs to
United States and start great companies
and the very interest to me being that
last year I heard there was a specific
proposal by the time and Steve Jobs that
died there's a lot of people in China
just worried about yn0 Steve Jobs in
China and there's one really funny
proposal from I think is the nimble
government they wanted to invest in 70
million won to like raise five thousand
Steve Jobs and that to me was like boys
from Brazil that's pretty scary yeah
that means like a raising chicken or
like yeah go there yeah yeah but do you
think this will work or like what
exactly
and maybe loosely get outside as well
just generally I hope it's such a
difficult question like what really
leads to innovation and it is something
very unique to us right here in Silicon
Valley especially Stanford kind of at
the center of it all it's a great
discussion for everyone in the room here
I don't claim to have all the answers on
it but I have thought about it a little
bit recently because we are having
discussions on this internally I think
at the end of the day just one idea
comes to mind is I think people really
benefit to be innovative from being
interdisciplinary so stop Thomas yeah
just an Australian I don't put home the
family the switching hi Ali all this to
say how they are the issue take a Steve
jumpluff sentence for so easily Antonio
to see Angela
Kazuya Tassie OMG so joy issue JAMA so
it has a tassel curbing like I don't put
home family and a gentle disciplined I
don't find me and Digger knowledge know
how some are I think this is very
important like how do you actually
encourage people to integrate I don't
know enough about the Chinese education
subscribe didn't go through it myself so
I can't say like this is how the Chinese
education system works but my sense is
like generally speaking it tends to lead
you in a certain direction like you're
going to be engineer you need to get
good grades in fact you need to be like
genius at math and all this stuff but
like our people saying and you know it's
also pretty cool if you know how to play
guitar in your painter I think like
somehow like that doesn't really enter
the picture in China very often it's not
just only the education system I think
it's also cultural I think it's like
maybe even parents you know I'm parents
who I wish you all like everyone the
society can kind of share some of the
blame this is pretty much the how it is
honestly like and I think like when you
look at someone like a Steve Jobs the
kind of like a Renaissance man like they
they know a lot about fonts and they
know a lot about chips you know fosters
today goods that what how do you say fun
said Chinese I don't know whatever you
know fought like there's like very
artistic there right like someone who's
interested in fonts and he that's like
the secret to apples early successes
that we we had beautiful fonts I mean
you could just eat the fonts they're so
beautiful there's nothing to do with the
the speed of the processing power that
goes but he brought this all together
right calligraphy calligraphy is the
future
that's very Chinese right and yeah like
almost every change person these artists
already exactly yeah yeah yeah yes yeah
under the wise your musician is talking
by the tones right you've nailed the
tone yeah have I told it I don't know
ape ability but I think it's important
now you know but maybe that's like the
next step for China and I don't know I
don't think you really leave it to
anyone I think it's like up to the
individual and
and you know like encouraging schools
like schools that encourage you to also
play instruments squares include
encourage you to be an engineer but also
when painting like and also just
encouraging people to study kind of
whatever they want like I think a lot of
Stanford kids can probably you have to
get do it enough studying to get this
degree here but then meanwhile you can
be setting all kinds of crazy stuff as
well as the thing you had to do to get
your degree in engineering degree
whatever it was and I think that's a
starting point there's a lot more
factors than that but that's a good
starting point
Lucy you so much thank you good oh yeah
sorry I will take we'll take the next
question and hopefully address it to
Lucy don't be good and then yes this
lady here and then we'll take this
gentleman who will wrap up if it could
be addressed to Lucy if you could yeah
Custer producer sodunke
I should ask questioning English yes
opinion okay now you know uh-huh uh-huh
nothing you have to kill me Oh actually
actually can you do an English because I
know it'll okay you didn't Chinese
rights right so maybe gee maybe they
have to they have a sec sorry okay so
you go fish fountain ding da do go to
court see the teacher hello Lisa Panther
genitive human John she's sure Alibaba
Alibaba should saw you good chant that
Harlan County minion John Johnson Batman
xuxian sword so you could Santana hell
yeah
19 year woman I dig topic should going
to take Cheyenne was in no chance II
know what I'm trying to show you mercy
no Chauncey door shotgun Oh g-god Oh
chanting she'll consider you know John
how can that mean urging a title she
chief people officer
so Sancho you guys you got back Anabella
video to that you got so treaty ago John
Cena Chico no John you shame I don't see
Taj on agenda you go P Garcia got me
detention easing into I take chief
people officer
so Alibaba Chitra Nino Jonny
romance Asia - OH - alibaba's little en
casa da da da da cunha HR sweetie
sweetie
- oh go to Italia valium no cantos Reba
Hart swaddle you guys marketing you guys
Shh our yummy potato Putin so like a hot
item so it hockey society is also fun
challenge turns carousel the citizen
swimming Jesus Ortega alibi from
solidity encourage your faith and Jung
soo-jung suit and a torso ha so it is a
deeper water has leaked start up the
show home to token white one day she
setting changing Gao LAN ho ho just need
a fun way holding short I got ma who
don't manage my coat on that this year
c18 Suzie don't see on patio value the
multi go take a sitting justice any Ally
it's me okay Bianco me it's me okay
penguin sorry not eager with an 20
Joshua chief people officer take a
just to our bubble ice what has he given
what what did you see
term procedure that the to Alibaba is
fantastic of interference on yalla just
a convenient hello HR pander significant
financial Miyata grow even wanted so the
singing slowly take a yahoo to control
Qin now the organizers show Ali Parvati
HR Haldeman quality go TC Simeon woman
deleted on watch as quantity 2 neo geo
Jesus face hung treaty our city though
push the Kohala procedure good to see
you leave me and johann du duta-de I
hope you saw how we can have a canal ad
hoc khoa do Co consider Hawking ha
pensando entreaty de agua de to bank and
had a goat honk and Hidatsa go Pokemon
que tu crois que su alejandro de Acho
cuddly deep offenses empathy decision to
the treaty and three hold needs emerge
she get hardships endured hang in the
energetic performance pallets data you
offenses amp and decision - dissension
should can hardly go to undo that eagle
phone we had to go children title period
so he tell you when no higher battle
dissension she can hide a take a Korean
June show Katie good hundred translation
me on the phone with a sheet erosion
sweetie get interference on Shui when
Ali Baba Ramdev Ohioans hey Chico Fabian
Doha your face hunter
she talked a good honto they take a
quantity ago - and couple wine change -
sugar don't we see a zoo without without
nudity wait hold on see this last one
because you been very patient but super
quick and sure quick answer sorry okay
what very quick question uh you know
everyone's very excited about Wei Shen /
WeChat what is the grand vision I really
appreciate that that's really nice
you don't work intensive no no no she
didn't work for Alabam I think well I
think you know it's it's doing well in
China it's actually the first time ever
that it seems like we've been able to
appeal to like the people in X the
Gangnam style lap right I mean it's
transcending people are like yeah like
like older people are willing to use it
people that are like white-collar work
so that's really exciting I don't think
we did anything special to get that it's
just like the first time it happened I
think because we start on smartphones
and maybe in the early stages the people
using the service on smartphones happen
to be like more like white-collar
workers or kind of more elitist you know
the context of China I hate to use that
term but like you know kind of higher
end users
you know like for every product at $0.10
we just iterate we work very closely
with customers we try to understand
their needs and we just keep iterating
so I think that's like there's got to be
a lot of more services coming up but
it's really coming out of deep
interactions with WeChat users one thing
that's really exciting particulate from
my perspective is like the international
guy at $0.10 is that it started growing
pretty rapidly outside of China it's
like well the first time ever I can
remember we had a 10 cent product that
organically drew grew a lot we're like I
think we're number one in not just like
you know greater China Hong Kong Taiwan
but like also like Malaysia Singapore
Vietnam Thailand and South we were like
really strong and tricky a couple weeks
ago I don't know where we are right now
I'd have to check but we're like number
one for a couple weeks in Turkey like
we're doing really strong in Saudi
Arabia and some other countries so that
was all really organic so that's very
exciting
I'd love to see us do more
internationally we have a small team
that's working on getting us actually
you know we don't do a lot of marketing
necessarily we really try to cater the
product to the users in other countries
so that's pretty challenging for us to
think deeply about Chinese users think
deeply about like Western users like
people around here in Palo Alto like
talking to users around here and doing
both of those well at the same time
because that's really really never been
done before at least in like
communication services or social
networking like I don't think there's
been a service that's truly like covered
China and the West before so that's a
really big challenge like I mean
Facebook's big but they're not really in
China and like you know we've done
things in China we're not out of here so
that's a challenge because the China
markets like at least twice as big as US
so any requests coming from China is
like going to have more magnitude than
even something from the US because it's
twice more than twice as big and it's
growing and the u.s. is pretty much
thought the technology shift to the
mobile that maybe brings it brings it to
me yeah so yeah so if I'm kind of
muddling through an answer that's
because like that's kind of where we're
going step by step we're focusing on
users we're trying to get the product to
be more attractive to users outside of
China at the same time like improving it
in China I'd love to see it get more
traction I'm actually really happy that
you raised the question that's nice
because it's the first time anyone ever
cared about a 10 set service outside of
China that I can remember so thank you
yeah all right thank you you're shady
all right we're done thank you very much
David and Lucy a big round of applause
you